we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
this is really funny so last week
when i was teasing the bonus show
previewing the stories on the bonus show
i had a verbal slip and i i called it
the boner show
and we chose not to edit it out because
we don't edit the show we actually
we do the show is just we just film it
and that's the show and it was sort of
funny
and there were expectedly memes and
there were
songs and remixes and all this different
stuff but there are now lots of callers
who are casually referring to it as the
boner show in voicemails
and that's not even like the main point
of the call and i have one such call
today about that but this is actually
really really interesting
uh the other day pat and i took the new
york times
dialect quiz i mentioned having friends
from the south who claim i have a new
york accent and sometimes people call
into the show and say i have a boston
accent but i don't have either i didn't
grow up in boston or new york
and i did this new york times dialect
quiz and it came back
saying i have a southern western new
england accent primarily which is
accurate that's exactly where i grew up
and that i have elements of my uh
dialect
in english that are typically from
yonkers new york and pembroke pines
florida
now i hypothesized i wonder
if there is some aspect of what is
sometimes called
the jewish american dialect that would
be centered around yonkers and pembroke
pines that has
kind of uh that there are traces of it
in my speech and this caller who again
casually refers to the bonus show as the
boner show
has a different explanation for those
elements of my speech take a listen this
is really interesting
hey david i was listening to your bonus
show the other day
and you were talking about how you took
the quiz to determine your dialect
yes and i believe that one of the
pin it pinpointed you to be having a
dialect from the pembroke pines florida
area
well i have an office in pembroke pines
i'm familiar with the area
and i believe you can attributed that to
perhaps your jewish heritage but i would
like to set the record straight on yeah
please
because pembroke fines has a very high
hispanic population
about over 40 percent hispanic primarily
college educated
mostly from south america so i believe
that may be where
that hint of dialect may have come from
so
that is very very interesting and
in fact um if you look at
uh pembroke at the yonkers new york
which is the other place where my my
accent has
traces has roots there's also a large
hispanic population in yonkers so
that may be accurate and i was thinking
back you know when i first moved to the
united states i only knew two words i
knew the word stop and i knew the word
blue
and i remember leaving jfk airport and
seeing a stop sign
what are the odds you know five-year-old
me what are the odds that
right away i see a word that i know this
is going to go really really easily it's
going to be great
and of course it was difficult but the
early folks
when i was in school they had you know
sort of like helpers
this is when schools i think were maybe
better funded and there was more
staffing but
some of the other um kids who were
learning english coming from
spanish-speaking countries there were
there were sort of like helpers who
spoke english with accents they were
native spanish speakers who spoke
english with accents
and i wonder my early english exposure
other than mr rogers was my parents who
speak english with an accent
sourced from spanish language and
the helpers at school who would have
that exact same
accent in english having learned english
as a second language so i believe that
this caller
may very much be onto something very
very much beyond to something okay
that's it i went on for a long time but
that's the story
on today's bonus show texas has now sued
four different states over election
results
to try to overturn the election for
donald trump does texas even have
standing to sue other states we will
talk about that on today's
bonus show australia is going to make
facebook and google pay news outlets for
content how will that work
we will discuss it and rudy giuliani i
mean
think about the absurdity of this rudy
giuliani
yesterday went on a rant against
masks and against covid restrictions
from his hospital room where he is being
treated
for coronavirus which he caught by not
wearing a mask and traveling around the
country
it's beyond belief all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a
member at joinpakman.com coupon code
available if you want it fresh start
or get access to the bonus show by
becoming a
patron at patreon.com
pakman show